You’re a new SCP Foundation researcher on
a tour of Site 17, familiarizing yourself
with the location and its
many anomalous inhabitants.
It’s the second-largest Foundation containment
site out there, and it’s also the kind of
job that most junior researchers dream of:
Low-risk humanoid containment, baby.
Most of the inhabitants in your sector are
cordial, willing to comply with orders from
staff, and seem - for all intents and purposes
- pretty much human.
You pass from door to door, looking through
the viewing hatch of each one.
You can’t believe what you’re seeing - it’s
a wonderful who’s who of anomalous humanoids.
You see the wise, bearded face of SCP-343,
known to some as God.
You see the blue eyes and shining blond hair
of Iris - SCP-105 - looking wistfully into
a polaroid picture.
You see the tanned, melancholic face of Cain,
SCP-073, as he stares off
into the middle-distance.
Face after face after face passes, you can
see yourself getting more familiar with each
one.
Yes, your time here will be-
Wait, was that Hitler!?
You stop and walk back to the door you just
passed, where you can’t help but stop and
stare in disbelief.
Yes, it’s him, it’s got to be him!
You recognize the unpleasant sneer.
The hideous combover.
The silly little toothbrush mustache.
The SCP Foundation seems to have Adolf Hitler,
the former leader of the Third Reich in World
War II, in active containment, and his designation
is SCP-2430.
You’ve seen killer toasters and masks that
can take over people’s minds, but you’ve
never seen anything as surreal as this!
You immediately run to your superior, and
ask how and why Hitler is in one of the Site
17 humanoid containment cells.
Your superior chuckles.
Buckle in, because we can guarantee it’s
one of the most insane stories you’ve ever
heard…
It’s late April, 1945, and the Soviets are
rampaging through Nazi Germany, destroying
everything in their path.
The German forces have been nearly obliterated,
and Hitler and the rest of his Reich Chancellery
have retreated into a secure bunker beneath
Berlin.
There on April 30th, ten days after his 56th
birthday, Hitler died.
This was truly unfortunate for the Soviets,
as they wished to have had the chance to kill
him themselves.
Two days later, Soviet forces stormed the
Führerbunker.
It was little more than a formality at that
point, as the news of Hitler’s death had
already gone public.
By the time they arrived, all that was left
of Hitler was a pile of mostly burned remains
- a fitting end for someone who had caused
that same cruel fate for so many others.
They collected what was left of Hitler’s
body, and brought it back to the fatherland,
a kind of trophy for their nation.
But Hitler dying before Joseph Stalin could
get his hands on him, was not what Stalin
wanted.
Hitler had not only caused the deaths of millions
of Russians, he had personally betrayed Stalin’s
trust.
And when you betray Stalin, bad things happen
to you.
Very very bad things.
Two years earlier, in 1943, Soviet forces
had raided a camp in Janowska belonging to
the Obskurakorps.
Think of them as the Nazi’s own version
of the SCP Foundation, who were hellbent on
gathering anomalous people and artifacts to
increase the power of the Third Reich.
They were a far more militant offshoot of
the Thule Society, a group that described
itself as a “Study Group for Germanic Antiquity.”
While this may seem innocent, the Thule Society
were actually a racist cult, closely aligned
with the goals and ideals of the German Nazi
Party.
Many have also speculated that they were heavily
involved in the Occult, and it’s this mysticism
obsessed offshoot that went on to form the
Obskurakorps.
And in their Janowska base, they’d obtained
a hundred pieces of enchanted occult flesh
with human skeletons embedded in each of them.
This flesh was believed to originate from
the mythological Sæhrímnir,
the beast hunted and eaten again and again
by the pantheon of Norse gods, having the
qualities of both a wild boar and a goat.
The flesh can bond to skeletons, and give
them a quality somewhat like immortality:
Any flesh cut from them will regrow, time
and time again, if given a rest period.
Now that he had both the flesh of Sæhrímnir
and Hitler’s burnt remains, Stalin had an
idea.
A perfect way to not only bring satisfaction
to the Russian people and the world, but to
finally exact the true revenge that Hitler
had denied to him.
He called it Project Judecca, named after
the very bottom level of Hell, reserved for
betrayers like Judas.
A perfect tribute for an old ally turned enemy.
He couldn’t kill Hitler before, but if Stalin
was going to get the chance, Hitler needed
to live again.
For years, Stalin’s stop scientists tried
to use arcane methods to resurrect Hitler
by combining his remains with the flesh of
Sæhrímnir.
At times, they even came close to creating
a new Hitler, but there was one huge issue:
The creature they created could not feel pain,
and for Stalin’s plans of violent and painful
retribution, the lack of suffering simply
would not do.
They destroyed what they had created, and
went back to the drawing board.
Stalin would stop at nothing to get what he
wanted - even if it meant breaking every law
of nature in the process.
In order to make his twisted dream a reality,
Stalin formed an unholy alliance with a group
known as the Uralic flesh-crafters, a Neo-Sarkic
Cult that was a branch of the nightmarish
religion of Sarkicism.
This group essentially worships avatars of
flesh, corruption, and disease, and are behind
some of the most terrifying and disgusting
anomalies out there - including The Flesh
That Hates and The Bone Orchard.
True Sarkicists, who show the proper devotion
to their vile deities and know the right rituals
to contact them, are often granted anomalous
powers to spread the Sarkic influence further
across the known dimensions.
These powers will usually involve having a
supernatural ability to manipulate the flesh
of themselves and others, allowing them to
enhance their bodies, cheat death, and warp
their enemies beyond repair.
They can sometimes even create life, if they’re
a powerful enough acolyte of Sarkicism.
And it was because of these powers that Stalin
wanted the Uralic flesh-crafters under his
command.
In exchange for their participation, he would
give them a vast quantity of the flesh of
Sæhrímnir, which they could use for their
own sinister Sarkic purposes.
A deal was struck, and the
true work of resurrecting
Hitler began.
Stalin was very specific in his requirements.
He gave the Uralic flesh-crafters extra bones
to compensate for what had gone missing from
Hitler’s burnt remains.
He also gave them samples of the flesh of
Sæhrímnir to achieve the desired effects
of a near-immortal tolerance for damage.
However, Stalin demanded that they heighten
this new Hitler’s capacity to experience
pain, so that every suffering inflicted on
him would be three times worse than anyone
else.
And true to their word, the flesh-crafters
got to work, and began creating just such
a creature.
By now it was the early 1950s, and Stalin
was putting the pieces in place for his grand
revenge.
Once the new Hitler was finished, he would
hold a new trial for him in the Russian courts,
where he would preside over the sentencing
personally.
Once the new Hitler was done,
the Uralic flesh-crafters
were rewarded for their participation in Project
Judecca with 4000 kilogram of the flesh of
Sæhrímnir.
Stalin now had his very own personal Hitler
chew toy, that he could maim and torture as
much as he pleased, knowing he would always
heal and soon be ready for more.
In their infinite generosity, the flesh-crafters
even taught Stalin a new method of torment
for his old enemy: A process known as the
Rite of Nyúz.
It’s a torture that’s been described by
many as being like the Chinese Lingchi, also
known as the lingering death, or slow slicing,
but it is probably best known as the death
by a thousand cuts.
The Soviets and the Sarkics parted ways.
For the next few years, Stalin took a great
deal of pleasure in visiting Hitler’s cage
now and then to torture him, until Stalin
himself eventually passed away from natural
causes.
The GRU-P Division, which is essentially the
Soviet answer to the SCP Foundation, decided
it would be best to do away with the immortal
Hitler clone after Stalin’s death.
He no longer served any purpose, and no matter
how hard they tried, they couldn’t permanently
kill him, either.
In the end, they settled on a kind of compromise:
He would be buried alive and forgotten, forced
to live a torturous eternity that he could
never escape.
Until, of course, he was dug up and rescued
by none other than members of OBSKURA, a modern
splinter group of the original Obskurakorps.
Like many high profile Nazis who’d escaped
the war, the new Hitler was spirited away
to a safehouse run by sympathizers in Argentina.
The ones taking care of him received the following
correspondence from the OBSKURA agents who’d
first dug the new Hitler back up:
“We have managed to rescue the Führer and
bring him to safety.
But he is effectively dead on the inside.
I blame the Reds for their inhumane treatment
of the Führer, who may have been bewitched
by the Reds' wunderwaffe.
I wish we could mercy kill him, but we've
tried everything.
He just won't perish.
Don't abandon him; he's too distinct in plain
sight.”
They didn’t have the new Hitler for long
though.
In 1960, efforts to hunt down the remaining
Nazi fugitives increased in intensity.
The new Hitler was soon captured by Mossad
Agents searching for Nazis in Buenos Aires,
and then remanded to the containment of the
SCP Foundation when they realized that he
had a number of anomalous properties.
Such as his incredible regenerative abilities,
as well as the fact that his DNA seems to
be based on that of a wild boar and goat rather
than a human.
However, X-Rays conducted by the Foundation
have discovered traces of cyanide still in
his system, as well as traces of lead in his
skull where the bone has regrown over the
bullet.
In other words, it was unquestionably the
real Hitler, and he was now in Foundation
custody forevermore.
It’s such a wild story, even by Foundation
standards, that you can barely summon the
words to respond once your supervisor is finished.
He just stands there with a slight smile,
basking in your amazement.
Before you can even ask again, he confirms
the facts one more time: Yes, it is the real
Hitler, the only functional difference is
that he can’t die and he has a heightened
sense of pain compared to most people.
You think on what you’ve just been told
for a moment, and then you have only one question.
“Are we allowed to punch him?”
Your supervisor smiles and says, “Of course.
We all do.”
Now go check out “SCP-1861 - The Crew of
the HMS Wintersheimer” and “SCP-3999 - I
Am At The Center of Everything That Happens
To Me” for more nightmarish SCPs!